[Musique]
michel onfray bonsoir j'ai survécu à un
infarctus deux avc et un an des manuels
macron et vous êtes toujours là oui un
an de macron c'est le pire quand même si
c'est pire qu'un infarctus
alors michel vous racontez votre
deuxième avc dans un livre intitulé le
deuil de la mélancolie journal d'un avc
c'est un livre splendide et je dis pas
ça parce qu'il met dédié je dis ça parce
qu'il est aussi dédié à ma femme en fait
lorsque les gens me disent pourquoi est
ce que le livre de michel onfray était
dédié jeudi parce que ma pensée l'à
beaucoup inspiré
alors tout commence sur un quai de la
gare saint lazare mais la sncf n'est
pour rien en faire elle est arrivée à
leur set facile
au bout du quai je me suis sentie comme
troué par une lumière intérieure percée
forêt traversée perforé dans le cerveau
oui j'étais allé faire un tour sur les
traces d' art au mexique et j'avais vu
des clous d'utiliser les pré colombien
pour faire des sacrifices et en
obsidienne quand j'avais vu ses clous ça
devait donner une drôle de sensation
dans le cerveau et j'ai une impression
vraiment qu'on montrait un trou dans le
cerveau avec un coup de matraque
électrique gd m'effondrer obsidian
la cinq médecins différents ne font pas
le bon diagnostic et le 2 février 2018
vous êtes sur le plateau d' audrey
crespo mara et en vous entendant dire du
bien des manuels macron elle s'inquiète
sait pas exactement avec 2 s'est passé
mais un peu parce qu'effectivement j'ai
eu je suis rentré immédiatement dans la
foulée j'ai pris le train de retour je
veux aller aux urgences à caen et le mon
médecin me dit le médecin que j'ai vu
aux urgences pas dit ça n'est pas un avc
j'ai appelé mon toubib qui m'a dit ça
n'est pas un avc un ami qu'il l'était
mais il l'est plus c'était aux airelles
qui me dit ça n'est pas un avc j'ai fait
mon cours à l'université populaire le
lendemain y avait mille personnes j'ai
trouvé du coup tout de même j'avais des
papillons partout autour des yeux un
terrible mal de tête j'ai fait une
conférence en plus le jeudi et puis
j'étais sur le plateau de voitures
d'audrey en fait audrey vos interviews
ensuite elle nous envoie un sms dans le
taxi en visant michèle devriez quand
même aller voir un radiologue quoi pour
faire un irm elle m'appelle moi j'étais
en train de déjeuner et c'est vrai que
je réponds à personne sauf à ma femme
évidemment elle me dit qu'il faut
trouver un radiologue appel gombert il
faut trouver un radiologue pour pour
michel et vous y allez oui on m'a fait
un texto adorable en me disant je vous
en conjure détourner votre taxi elle est
cet endroit où on fera une irm et de
fait c'est là qu'on a vu qu'il y avait
une vraie patate et c'était
c'était un avc voilà là vous êtes
hospitalisé donc à foch donc cinq
médecins étaient passés à côté le pire
de tous dit vous si le docteur
parce que lui vous avez assuré qu'il
n'est pas un avc mais ensuite il a nié
avoir faire un faux diagnostic en
maintenant fait qu'il savait que c'est
un avc mais qui vous l'avez pas dit pour
vous épargner des émotions
oui c'est d'abord quelqu'un qui m'a
intimes a demandé comment allait manger
du rin alors je me suis demandé pourquoi
si j'avais un premier avec ma prostate
je vois bien qu'il ya des relations
entre entre ma prostate et mon cerveau
mais je vois pas là au moment précis où
ça aurait pu passer ce genre là et il
s'est trompé de will a fait une erreur
de diagnostic il m'a dit vous avez un
problème de vitré donc l'oeil mais après
un rendez vous chez un ophtalmo à paris
cet après midi vous irez voir etc et
quand je suis allé chez le docteur dont
berne une heure plus tard lui m'a dit
non non pas du tout c'est un avc alors
les causes de cet avc en fait c'est que
les l'hédonisme sa bouche les artères
quoi c'est ça
oui si on en met mais il n'y a pas de
problèmes de tuyauteries que ça le
problème j'ai fait un infarctus à 28 ans
vous l'avez rappelé il n'y a pas
d'explication à notre avis un premier
avc pas d'explication deuxième avc pas
d'explication né dans la médecine de
molière dans deux siècles on rira de
notre propre média fourier soins
diafoirus de ce qu'on dira ah ben voilà
il avait juste pas un gène qui on a
isolé et puis voilà alors aujourd'hui on
vous dit il faut pas ceci faut pas cela
par exemple on vous dit est ce que vous
faites bien du sport ce que vous faites
du vélo est ce qu'on fait de la natation
vous buvez peut-être trop vieux métro
vous êtes peut-être stresser les enfants
dans leurs berceaux font des avc ils
sont peu susceptibles de mal manger
grosbois quatre ans les cultes ne pas
faire assez de vélo à six mois ont fait
des avc en fait quand votre femme est
décédée vous le dites dans livrés pensé
partir avec elle est en fait vous êtes
retrouvé seul un fidèle à votre promesse
il fallait vivre quand même et là vous
n'êtes ni à manger à boire à prendre
trop de médicaments et à courir dans
tous les sens pour vous occuper l'esprit
un peu je bois depuis toujours mais
d'être trousses jamais été ivres mais
j'étais dans des quantités un peu
d'ordre et j'ai pris 15 kilos à 5 ans m
et donc ces quinze kilos personne ne m'a
dit ce serait bien que tu les perds 10
comprimés un médecin un médecin ami qui
aurait pu me dire font un peu ça ne fera
pas de mal prenait beaucoup de
médicaments c'est à dire antibiotiques
cortisone antihistaminiques sur plein de
choses oui fait des allergies ouais
c'est ça acariens donc des villes ces
zones que l'on commencé antibiotiques
cortisone etc et on accumule une espèce
de pollution pharmaceutique et
médicamenteuses et on dira aussi
probablement un jour combien les
médicaments tu vois là il faut le dire
aux gens faut pas trop en prendre moi
non voilà en fait vous étiez en train
vous suicider à petit feu d'une certaine
façon oui je crois que j'essayais d'être
fidèle à ma parole sans envoyer un coup
de fusil dans la tête je crois que
j'étais en train de me suis fixé
doucement et que ce suicide ou bien nous
dire où il va falloir tout soit clair
est-ce que c'est un vrai suicide ou
voilà voilà et si c'est pas un vrai
suicide alors on continue à vivre et si
on continue alors il faut faire d'où le
titre le deuil de la mélancolique voilà
alors les conséquences de tout ça c'est
effectivement vous avez changé de mode
de vie donc j'ai perdu 10 15 kg c'est
cependant bien le plus dur c'est quoi
perdre 10 kilos ou perdre ses illusions
c'est perdre ses amis ouais parce que
effectivement il ya des gens qui ne font
plus signe des gens qui n'appelle pas il
ya des gens qui n'en a pas de textos et
des gens qui ont l'impression que les
avc sont contagieux et on ne se fait
piéger charognards aussi qui vous
appelle à l'hôpital pendant la dernière
interview de michel onfray oui olivier
les éditeurs savoir si vraiment je vais
encore pouvoir signer des contrats alors
au sujet de votre cerveau vous dites mon
cerveau s'avère être mon meilleur ami et
mon meilleur ennemi c'est vrai oui parce
que je suis sorti de mon milieu purement
milieu modeste milliers de mes parents
grâce aux livres grâce à l'écriture de
réseau à mon travail cérébral ah oui et
puis on se dit bon quand même là de deux
avc pour un seul personnage ça fait
quand même eau ou alors vous avez quand
même perdu un quart de votre champ
visuel
qui fait que là vous voyez pas du tout
laurent baffie qui vous fait un doigt
d'honneur sur le côté là laurent maurice
du progrès qu'il soit la hausse est de
bord supérieur gauche alors la mort rôde
autour de vous depuis votre enfance
vous êtes tenté par l' angoisse la mort
j'en ai pas peur mais je suis est elle
est présente ou et depuis depuis
toujours un jeu raconte un peu que j'ai
eu un vieux papa quand je suivais mon
père avait 38 ans et que très vite j'ai
eu peur qu'il parte et il partit à 88
ans et pendant tout ce temps là j'ai
toujours eu peur que quelqu'un un jour
arrive il ya un moment donné où on se
calme un peu avec ça mais c'est un peu
l'avers et le revers de la médaille ou
lorenzo le verso de la même feuille
c'est à dire que l'hédonisme n'est pas
possible sans un sentiment aigu de la
mort il faut savoir que la vie est
courte brève que chaque seconde perdue
est définitivement perdue on la
récupérera pas à la punition elle est
ici et maintenant qui a pas de paradis
ya pas de récompense ya rien au delà
mais qu' il veut il faut pas rater sa
vie on accule quoi la vie ne repasse pas
les plats aujourd'hui le malheur le
deuil est traitée comme une maladie oui
d'abord j'ai toujours dit depuis la mort
de mon père d'abord puis celle de marie
claude après qu' on ne fait pas son
deuil mecs le deuil qui nous fait et
donc on n'y pas un jour à ba oui voilà
il ya une espèce de feuille de route du
genre dans les 15 jours et se passe et
ce à trois semaines après un mois après
et vous allez passer parce si vous allez
passer par cela ça ne rien dire on perd
des gens qu'on aime qu'on n'aime pas on
perd des gens qu'on déteste on perd des
gens proches on perd des gens âgés on
s'est préparés à la mort de certains
certains partent d'un seul coup d'autres
ont 15 ans maladie cette année de
chimiothérapie pour marie-claude
non-stop donc évidemment il n'y a pas
une feuille de route du deuil mais c'est
le deuil qui nous fait parce
qu'effectivement il faut vivre avec ceux
qui sont partis et il faut pas succomber
ça il faut pas il faut pas succomber à
la mort des gens qui sont partis l'athée
que je suis se dit la meilleure façon
d'être fidèle aux gens qui sont morts
c'est de vivre sous le regard quand on
les a aimés et est en ce sens comme la
mort est acceptable
il ya un truc la chose à laquelle je
pense là la question colombo
[Musique]
christophe il ya un truc dernière chose
j'y repense la perquisition sélection de
bena là alors il arrive avec les flics
benalla n'a pas la clé de chez lui on
lui dit l'attaquent appelés ta femme il
n'a pas le numéro de sa femme il n'y a
qu'à appeler le commissariat ils ont
peut-être un bélier pour défoncer la
porte il n'y a pas de bélier au
commissariat ensuite ils partent ils
laissent pas de flics devant la porte
pendant la nuit et le lendemain matin le
coffre qui était si alexandre benalla on
sait pas ce qu'elle en qu'offre le
coffre a disparu il ya un syndicat de
police qui a porté plainte et le parquet
a refusé de de poursuivre et ensuite les
médias passent à autre chose en disant
ça n'intéresse plus les gens donc
l'affairé a été bouclée c'est pas un peu
bizarre aussi bizarre que je peux pas
vous dire d'accord mais c'est parait
normal c'est à minima croquignolesque
effectivement mais c'est bien il n'a pas
les clefs il sait pas où et sa femme etc
et le coffre disparaît donc il ya un
côté quand même un peu barrows rico
maintenant oui et puis après il a
déclaré que c'est qu'il avait peur que
hong kong briol ouais ok d'accord mais
c'est bien vous êtes honnête ah bah oui
là je peux difficilement vous dire autre
chose que ça
roberto saviano la mafia et salvini
veulent votre mort ça prouve au moins
que vous êtes quelqu'un de bien
les français vous connaissent par vos
livres et par la série gomorra mais pour
ceux qui ne vous connaîtraient pas
encore on regarde c'était la première
fois qu'on a entendu parler de vous ici
en 2007 magnéto serge nous souhaitions
le rencontrer à naples trop dangereux
pour lui c'est à rome que roberto
saviano nous a donné rendez vous pour
une brève promenade dans un jardin
public entouré de ses gardes du corps
âgé de 28 ans cet écrivain napolitain a
osé défier la camorra la puissante mafia
locale dans son livre une enquête qui a
duré six ans il raconte en détail sa
mainmise sur la ville et surtout il
donne les noms des chefs de clans qui
depuis ont juré de l'assassiner
combien d'années je vis avec lise et de
la motion d'abord parce que j'ai grandi
sur un territoire où des dizaines de
personnes que je connaissais ont été
abattus comme je l'écris dans mon livre
le premier mort par balle ce que j'ai vu
j'avais 12 ans j'ai grandi sur un
territoire où il y avait 80 en chargeant
son territoire c'est naples ces
quartiers pauvres ces règlements de
compte sa mafia omniprésente du trafic
du ciment à celui de la cocaïne un monde
parallèle qui a résisté à tous les
assauts de l'état italien pour le
démanteler
je le dis sans tracker fausses c'est une
force capitaliste parce que cette mafia
la camorra évolue sans cesse parce que
la concurrence à l'intérieur et sans
pitié mais la concurrence est aussi les
tribunaux les forces de police la police
arrive à des mots clés enclos lorsque
celui ci est faible et en l'éliminant
ont créé un espace pour un nouveau club
roberto saviano n'a pas renoncé et
écrire sur la camorra à rome sa maison
d'édition lui a aménagé un bureau bien à
l'abri dans ses sous-sols ou ses gardes
du corps peuvent surveiller l'unique
entrée
je reconnais que souvent le matin je me
réveille en maudissant ce que j'ai fait
mais je le referais 300 fois parce que
c'était nécessaire d'écrire tout cela je
lis parfois des moments très difficiles
ça serait stupide de le nier son livre
s'appelle gomorra comme gomorrhe la cité
de l'ancien testament que dieu détruisit
par le feu à cause de ces péchés naples
gomorrhe des temps modernes la cité du
mâle selon roberto saviano
alors roberto saviano vous avez
découvert que la mafia pouvait être
embarrassée par la littérature c'est
incroyable
alors c'est vrai cela oui c'est vrai
évitez la mafia a peur de la lumière
mafia mais savent très bien qui dit à la
police d enquête des juges des tribunaux
les homicides enfin seulement l'objet
des articles de la presse rien de plus
par contre la mafia peur des yeux et des
oreilles de l'électeur
les spectateurs à la mafia veut vous
tuer et jette une information qui est
validée par de nombreux mafieux repenti
qui collaborent avec la justice depuis
12 ans vous aviez 26 ans à l'époque vous
vivez sous protection policière entre
deux planches jamais sans vos gardes du
corps vous dites je suis complètement
paranoïaque je suis brisé en petits
morceaux on ne m'a pas tué mais on ne
m'a pas laissé vivant non plus extrêmes
voire oui c'est bizarre
lorsque les premières menaces me sont
arrivées
ce format c'était plutôt des
informations
c'est comme si on me prévenait c'est
quoi ces constats l'air bien moment
donné on est obligé de se justifier
d'être vivant
on aurait dû tout de suite il ya dix ans
on n'est ce pas comment ça se fait qu'il
est toujours en vie
alors tu n'es pas dangereux
ce n'est qu'une mise en scène pour
vendre des livres magnelli brissonneau
axonais force énorme il a dit mais ce
n'est peut-être pas noble de le dire
mais je crois que mes livres sont ma
vengeance est-ce qu'en france il y à la
mafia j'ai ouï les des motos vote et les
très fortes en plus on me répétait la
foule tour je ne sais pas pourquoi dans
la culture française
testa vaste aperçu cette perception
après la deuxième guerre mondiale
forçons pas d'attention à mars il ya
peut-être
on a fait attention à marseille
s'est qualifié que des organisations
mafieuses françaises sont partis
il suffit de penser que tout la cocaïne
qui arrivent en france certains nas ou
d'amérique à part
arrive en afrique équatoriale
ensuite ce sont les corses qui la porte
en france et la mafia corse est très
forte peut-être parce qu'en france il
n'y a pas de sens donc la vad mafia
c'est peut-être ça aussi
12h07 vasseur c'est une bonne
observation c'est une bonne remarque les
je m'assigne je voudrais chamonix que le
nombre de morts à marseille a dépassé le
lendemain à naples et le nombre de morts
à naples est plus important que le
nombre de morts dans la bande de gaza
est certain mais tout à fait et si
c'était à refaire tout ça est ce que
vous le referiez n'aurait cependant
manier la chorale je réponds pas de
façon courageuse mais je ne le referais
pas c'est devenu un héros est un héros
moderne vous êtes notre héros vous
voulez venger les morts de la mafia
c'est ça l'histoire non
grasses beurre élimine définitivement
merci de m'avoir appelé héros
certaines parties des gens de mon pays
je ne suis pas du tout un héros alors
gomorra votre premier livre a été
traduit en 50 langues
il s'est vendu à une dizaine de millions
d'exemplaires dans le monde avant d'être
adapté au cinéma au théâtre et
évidemment en séries télévisées alors si
vous berlusconi vous accuse de donner
une mauvaise image de l'italie
c'est nous y est maudit effectivement ce
n'est pas le seul nous habite une très
vieille accusation lorsqu'on parle de de
ma vie a et bien on est en train de
faire la promotion de la culture
mafieuse c'est donc sur me disait
imagine une chambre dans le noir dans
laquelle je rentre et si j'ai lu à la
lumière et on voit un cadavre à la
louche et c'est la faute à la lumière
c'est ce qu'on me dit alors après le
succès de gomorra vous avez publié extra
pur un livre consacré à l'économie de la
cocaïne c'est un marché qui pèse quand
même 300 milliards de dollars
après la mafia sicilienne vous êtes mis
à dos les cartels mexicains
et aujourd'hui vous publiez votre
premier roman piranha ce aux éditions
gallimard
consacré aux baby gang alors comme il ya
des enfants soldats il y a des enfants
mafieux c'est
g qui se remet on
sait que je suis trop vous trouvez face
à une histoire incroyable
d'enfants âgés entre 10 10 heures
au sommet d'une organisation mafieuse
très puissant je n'étais pas
payante c'était pas des petits qu'il est
roux de petits pusher c'était vraiment
des chefs c'est incroyable cela a été
possible parce que ses enfants étaient
géniaux
heureusement c'est un génie qui était au
service du crime de la barbarie alors
piranha c'est un livre absolument
passionnant le livre raconte le parcours
de nicolas fiolet et de sa bande
d'adolescents sa part m ca son groupe
ils ont tous entre 14 et 18 ans il se
déplaçait son scooter ils sont armés ils
sont fascinés par la violence et par le
crime il ne croit qu'aux pouvoir et à
l'argent ils ont plus peur de devoir
vivre comme leurs parents que de la mort
c'est la mort tu es nonais publistar on
ne regarde plus la mort comme un risque
du métier comme un nez chez sita c'est
une nécessité
c'est la suite de ce choix ces enfants
veulent mourir après avoir des années
pendant lesquelles ils ont tout pris toi
je suis allé les voir les interviewer
bien évidemment les rescapés ils m'ont
demandé mais qu'est les tonnages j'ai
dit j'ai 38 ans
battue n'a aucune valeur qui compte
les personnes importantes mer à 20 ans
21 internat il m'a regardé avec c'est
incroyable cette attitude est une
nouvelle génération de caïds qui
remplace l'ancienne génération c'est la
génération des jeux vidéo la génération
des des réseaux sociaux on les appelle
les babys gangsters et leur monde et est
totalement binaire en fait c'est à dire
qu'elle est faible les forts les riches
et les pauvres les baiseurs et les
baisers kwassa kwassa la latika et réal
tassées ces produits c'est l'éthique si
on peut utiliser selon des organisations
mafieuses qui a deux choix qu il faut
tout au fond est ce que tu veux être
buzzer au baiser
regarde bien c'est peut-être la logique
de notre temps
pas seulement dans les la criminalité
organisée sont hospitalisés fia c'est un
hymne quoique c'est un monde sans pitié
ce qui est intéressant dans vos livres
et dans celui ci en particulier c'est
qu'en fait ça parle des jeunes mathieu
non celui là mais en fait ça parle de la
société moderne c'est là où ça une
dimension universelle en fait votre
livre
cette jeunesse décadente vous la
raconter mais vous ne la jugez pas
non parquet non je ne juge pas ces
personnes ne sont pas des bêtes
font pas partie d'une autre civilisation
qui concentrait novolyon raconte arena
projet ambitieux que je ne veux pas
raconter naples le monde noël monde doit
travailler je vois plutôt raconter le
monde à travers naples alors roberto
vous vous êtes mis à dos la camorra et
les cartels mexicains les baby geister
et vous êtes mis à dos le nouveau
mussolini matteo salvini vous l'appelez
le ministre de la pègre vous parlez de
50 millions d'euros volés par le parti
de salvini la ligue ou dit un jour pas
si lointain les italiens comprendront ce
qu'est vraiment un traître à la patrie
ce qui est en train de se passer en
italie
est très intéressant je trouve pour la
france à l'étal il faut que la france
regarde al hiti photo parce qu'elle va
voir son avenir matteo salvini start and
honour massoud chef mathieu salvini est
en train d'obtenir
ses élèves avec des arguments violent
considérant qu ils immigrent a t il même
si d'heure les immigrés
la cible numéro un de tous les maux
las potenza des populismes et qu'elle en
a besoin de la puissance du populisme
c'est qu'il n'a besoin de rien montré
sexuelle d'une arabia le populisme
reprend une colère qui est souvent
légitimes une déception qui est souvent
juste tu as posté via sommet et reprend
tous à tous pour des objectifs qui ne
sont pas du tout les bons objectifs et
il y accéder un jour on arrêtait la
maire monsieur me muluka noah koussa a
été accusé d'avoir favorisé
l'immigration clandestine un seul bateau
vite il n'a fait que sauver des vies en
réalité alors vous critiquez tellement
salvini que en juin dernier il vous a
menacé de vous retirer votre protection
policière magnéto serge ce seront les
institutions compétentes qui évalueront
s'ils courent un risque réel
parce qu'il me semble qu'il passe
beaucoup de temps à l'étranger
et ça me semble juste d'évaluer comment
l'argent des italiens on sait mais bon
c'est le cadet de mes soucis
selon toi salvini je suis heureux de
vivre comme ça depuis onze ans depuis
plus de 11 ans j'ai une escorte depuis
que j'ai 26 ans mais toi tu penses
menacé m'intimider ou consternant c'est
dans un gîte est sous une pression
énorme la pression du clan des casalesi
la pression de narco ce mexicain j'ai
plus peur de continuer à vivre comme ça
que de mourir pour ça et donc tu crois
vraiment que je peux avoir peur de toi
granit et bouffon 20
bouffonne
belle alors vous dites salvini préfère
s'attaquer aux migrants pour pouvoir
mettre de côté les autres sujets
sensibles
il préfère qu'on le traite de raciste
que de voleurs
et tout europe et qui limite leur
entière on irait sur le responsable de
tous les problèmes
ce n'est pas le cas
il n'y a aucune invasion en plus de cent
mille personnes qui arrivent chaque
année eh bien l'italie est un pays qui
est en train de perdre de plus en plus
de la population est en train de se
vider
mais on peut adapter vous choisir une
solution intermédiaire
le fait réfuter les migrants des laisser
mourir dans la mer ou de laisser tout
simplement ouvertes les frontières
nationales et des rides aller il vit ce
qu'elle est cette solution intermédiaire
c'est celle de donner des visas de
travail en europe on a refusé et
politique de visas il faudrait renouveau
prévoir ces visas pour l'afrique c'est
une solution
pour
arrêter le désir de venir en europe tout
simplement avec des embarcations de
fortune en risquant sa propre vie en
italie à quelques années sept cent mille
migrants avaient été
reconnus
oui
et en plus c'est le gouvernement de la
ligue telles que celles vivant parce
qu'on en avait besoin alors pour vous
les italiens sont écrasés sous le poids
d'une politique qui se fait dans les
talk shows et sur les réseaux sociaux
vous parlez d'une politique provocatrice
qui parle aux citoyens dévastés par des
décennies de berlusconisme et d'anti
berlusconisme vous vous sentez un peu
seul
on porte sur la butte ouates ge est
d'habitude au moins un petit peu et
promis d'y consacrer la mère d'à côté il
dit toujours que la merde est utile et
coût est utile pour le sol puis où
l'émirat difficile donc je pense que mes
racines vont être de plus en plus
fécondes
[Musique]
alors je rappelle le titre de votre
nouveau livre donc est consacrée aux
baby gangsters ça s'appelle piranha
c'est publié chez gallimard alors ça
ferait un film formidable mais roberto
l'industrie du cinéma en glorifiant la
mafia n'est t'elle pas le principal
ennemi de votre combat
est intéressante de man c'est une
question très intéressante le trouvera
lamy a strategy à ma stratégie est la
suivante protège hermida la non pharma
et film au 16e je ne veux jamais vu
faire des séries ou des films
superficiel et raconta les mécanismes
c'est pour cela que j'essaie de raconter
tout ce qui est derrière comment ça
marche l'économie comment ça marche le
pouvoir et queen et qu'ils gardent aller
mais c'est donc ce qui regarde les
séries que j'ai écrite
savent jusqu'au bout que je raconte une
réalité qui est authentique
et molto disent qu
il est très dangereux d'ailleurs de
penser que si je parle stordis du mal je
suis en train de diffuser le mal là
roberto il ya une dernière chose là j'y
pense c'est la question colombo
[Musique]
roberto si vous pouviez vous évader de
votre vie actuelle vous iriez où
mon poste devait gérer
quelque part où je pourrai recommencer à
zéro beauvais
ma présence ne mettrait pas en
difficulté ce qui même
j'ai gâché la vie de toutes les
personnes qui étaient autour de moi et
me man jeunes on pense comme la droite
je pense un endroit comme la nouvelle
zélande par exemple c'est l'om
michel
c'est dieu qui te parles tu m'entends
dis moi tu vois encore fait faux bond
non mais c'est toi qui n'a pas fait le
boulot jusqu'au bout puisque vous
tutoyez dieu on va
donc
devoir afin que depuis vatican ii mais
tu te crois en dieu oui c'est pas peu
fière d'eux on lui parle en français
michel tu n'as pas envie de voir ce que
la vie après la mort réserve
je serais assez tenté par l'hypothèse de
découvrir autre chose mais serait plutôt
de l'astrophysique nom qui
m'intéresserait sur ce terrain là les
laits monde inversé cette idée que le
temps peut-être comme on dit un raging
et c'est à dire qu'on veut on retourne
ça comme le doigt d'un banc on pourrait
presque revivre al'inverse qu'on aurait
vécu si dieu était vraiment un
astrophysicien ça m'intéresserait
d'avoir une conversation avec tué
dieu j'ai pas la barbe mais quand même
je vais j'essaie de paires d'yeux michel
qu'est ce qui te donne tu as envie de
rester sur terre à part le fromage et le
bon vin
ça c'est une bonne question
je crois que la vie en tant que tel est
une et une chose fabuleuse il ya en moi
une force qui me veut ce que nous que
personne appelée l'élan vital et cette
force qui me veut et elle est pour
l'instant plus forte qu'une force qui me
voudrait plus chez les femmes si ça
donne envie de rester sur terre non ça
on
on change d'époque canton quand on
change de décennies je vais avoir 60 ans
le 1er janvier prochain le rapport aux
femmes n'est plus du tout le même donc
ça paraît évident que le les collections
qu'on peut faire quand on a 30 ans on ne
les fait plus et on est plutôt non plus
dans une logique de cherchent quelque
juste quantité dans une logique de
qualité mais dès qu'on avait la quantité
épicurienne quand on a 30 ans on a la
qualité stoïcienne quand on a 75 ans on
perd
tout et ça il faut dire que j'ai vécu 37
ans avec marie claude et qu'il y avait
dans ma vie dorothée depuis 25 ans que
marie claude connaissait l'existence du
dorothée que dorothée connaissait
l'existence de de marie-claude heurté à
d'ailleurs été formidable sur la fin de
marie claude m'a aidé pour les
bouteilles d'oxygène de marie-claude et
des terrasses sont des choses qu'on
raconte pas vous
vaut mieux amener je le dis bon job et
jeudi pour la première fois je suis
content que ce soit chez vous et il se
fait que oui dorothée à un grand garçon
deux grandes filles victoire et avec
michaël qui est un adorable garçon ils
ont fait tous les deux un petit augustin
qui n'est pas simple mais qui est
adorable donc moi qui n'ai pas été père
je me retrouve grand père félicitations
michel onfray
je voudrais te poser une question qui me
taraude l'esprit
pourquoi top 100 du temps à vouloir
prouver que je n'existe pas
je ne prouve pas l'inexistence de dieu
je suis dans une logique
judéo-chrétienne j'en suis je suis un
judéo-chrétien à 20 siècle derrière nous
de quinze siècles on dire à jésus pour
moi est une fiction c'est pas un
personnage historique et ce qui
m'intéresse comme philosophe c'est de
voir comment tout ça ce qui construit
les routes et que dieu soit le dieu
monothéiste nom surgit crois pas avec
une barbe ou sans barbe qu'il est
d'aider des sentiments humains qu'ils
puissent se venger qui puisse
récompenser qu'il puisse tout voir tout
savoir ça pour moi c'est une fiction à
l'évidence mais j'ai pas envie forcément
de nommer dieu ce que l'astrophysique
nous enseigne s'il ya effectivement
d'autres vies ailleurs si notre vie
continue sous une autre forme moi
j'attends que là physiquement fasse la
démonstration et si on veut appeler ça
dieu j'ai rien contre dieu ce qui me
gêne dans le dieu ce sont les gens qui
s'en réclament pour imposer leur mode de
vie les autres pilotes nick quinn ce qui
me gêne dans dieu ce sont les religions
dit même michel
si j'existe est vraiment que
souhaiterais-tu madières disparaît
et maintenant c'est l'heure de lardy
quiz
[Musique]
alors dans son film stéphane plaza joue
un homme habité par l'esprit d'albert
einstein voilà alors cette semaine l'a
redit quiz est consacrée évidemment au
génie en hommage
à ces les deux c'est grave tension si
vous pensez à la retraite vous appuyez
sur le buzzer en mai seuil
cette affiche
ça c'est toi adacore vacances et son
besoin
très bien il est très court l'objet de
près première question quel prénom a été
inventé par william shakespeare à daphné
jessica bon juliette ou nabila
juliette non
jessica jessica bravo
à lui
compléter cette phrase de cédric villani
les maths c'est mieux que la politique
qu une séance de yoga qu'un éclair au
chocolat comme sexe
[Applaudissements]
en toi voulons
qu'elles étaient l'adresse de victor
hugo impasse de misérables rue des
châtiments place de jersey ou avenue
victor hugo et
victor hugo et en métal victor hugo
avenue victor hugo en son avenir à
volants bravo ça c'est le gros
bon sens sur une volée les flottements
dans les mêmes réponses tu viens moi
souvent un malade et qu'elle oeuvre a
été composé par mozart vient goûter mon
boudoir
plaisir de jouir au quand il pète il
trouve son slip
lèche mois le cul
[Applaudissements]
normal et l'appui à vos romans piège
moins que
moi qui suit un fil et escato voisard
mais mozart puisque à tous et en
allemand die l'aic miche ichard ouais
enfin c'est la même chose je
dis
souvent en tout cas non quelle
affirmation est vraie concernant pablo
picasso il a des ancêtres communs avec
andré citroën il a eu dix enfants cachés
il est est daltonien ou pascal obispo
est un anagramme de pablo picasso
si ça a marché devenu alors je vais même
duquel les trois premières
la nagra oui non
si stepanek - première se pressent que
la gardienne j'ai fait un bon bien sûr
les annales mais j'ai connu des bons
petits cadeaux pascal sommes plus qu'à
l'aube ispo - quels furent les derniers
mots d'albert einstein amer dans
la bouche
je me suis trompé la bonne formule c'est
pas égales mc pouvez-vous me raser la
moustache ou aucun ses derniers mots
était en allemand et l'infirmière à ses
côtés ne parlait pas avant
la dernière qu'elle allait
c'est pourquoi il tient la langue sur la
photo einstein non parce qu'en fait il
le faisait chier les mecs les paparazzi
les journalistes tout le monde
l'emmerdait et il aura tiré la langue
dont il est resté célèbre en fait c'est
une rébellion génie il était contre la
médiocrité
médiatique peut donc trouver au musée
galilée à florence le pyjama de galilée
une mèche de cheveux de galilée un
morceau du doigt de galilée ou le
prépuce de gars
[Applaudissements]
vraiment défaut
abbas hussein
comme rick coiffure un morceau de doigt
mais bravo
[Applaudissements]
c'est majeur de sa main droite et c'est
alors qu'un droit il ya les communes et
ouais gagner et la maintenance et le
super banco c'est à dire que celui metz
elle a regagné tigana a tout gagné
j'aurais mieux fait de répondre à celle
ci l ère semaine faire
in de ce sont les meilleurs groupes
derrière
avec sympathie
m
[Musique]
alors quelle seconde à inventer thierry
ardisson
quiz de ginai complètement
qui a tout inventé la télévision
n'a rien michel denisot qui avait dit un
truc très drôle ardisson avec le micro
qu'il n'a pas inventé c'est un but aux
marrons mais attention en se pensant aux
caprices à 2 caprice des dieux comme
génial il est fou il
n'est pas mort il est fou afflelou il
est fou c'est la crise au bon lait de
brebis ou quand c'est trop c'est trop
biko
quand c'est trop c'est trop
[Applaudissements]
et
alors donc dans cette émission les
gagnants darby quiz en droit à un éloge
par thierry ardisson attention
elle est fun et drôle
elle a la patate ne ratez pas daphné
bürki tous les après midi à 15h dit sur
france 2 elle est morte
sans oublier que daf est très bien
entouré pour son émission puisqu'il est
accompagné ont trop de pas andré
manoukian dit dédé doigts de fée le
grand spécialiste du plaisir féminin
de la bonne humeur du cul des bons plans
du cul des conseils psy du cul des
astuces beauté du cul des témoignages
bref ne manquez pas je t'aime et c'est
une émission pour se faire du bien tous
les jours à 15h10 sur france 2 les après
midi c'est daphné burki
alors guillaume canet et michel fau vous
êtes avec gilles lellouche camille ravin
et xavier beauvois la fiche de la mort
où une fête donc de cédric anger or le
pitch vous guillaume et gilles lellouche
dirigeait le miro de rome un peep-show à
pigalle en 1982 un soir des hommes
cagoulés débarque pour tout saccagé vous
êtes ruine est obligé de faire affaire
avec vos rivaux et notamment un certain
maurice goguel interprété par michel
faou et là vous produisez un film porno
pour vous refaire mais en vrai vous êtes
deux flics missionné par bercy pour
procéder à un énorme coup de filet dans
le business du x vous devez faire tomber
vos galles on regarde à quoi ça
ressemble magnéto ça
le ministre exige qu'on en finisse avec
le blanchiment dans le porno
on a notre vedette maurice bogeys pour
le flagrant délit fait affaire avec lui
et vous mais surveillée
le porno c'est le cinéma le plus cool à
faire
tu veux travailler comme producteur pour
moi
non les partants vous intéresse
as tu un bon film enfin pas trop bien
parce que le public aime pas ça
si on part sur des petites filles moi je
vous prie sans une demi journée 1 est-ce
que pamela peut aller soit douce avec
toi jeu et bien sûr que je peux viser
pas mais là tu fais pas maintenant que
tu aimes pas
je t'appelle unis pour trouver une seule
personne hormis sa chienne berger
divorcer à cause de nudisme est ma femme
avait peur des rhumes
mais par vas-y ma retraite ont pâti
qu'est ce que tu crois que ça doit faire
la bringue
à
oh non
s'attendaient justement non c'est moi
qui produit
si vous loupez votre coup moi j'en
connais qui vont rateront kong
on embarque l'équipe du film d'anne au
sérieux qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait trois
des exemples mais c'était pas prévu ça
va se finir ce [ __ ] de
[Musique]
c'est qui ça bah c'est jésus c'est une
photo ouais on reconnaît bien m'en
restait une photo
ça donne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
moi j'ai adoré donc déjà c'est très bien
réalisé ensuite vous incarnez avec
gilles deux personnages extrêmement bas
réduit l'année les côtelettes cousin sur
les joues roses à l'arrêt c'est génial
c'est un sérieux le buzzer insatiable et
vous alors à calais pour le voir il a
les cheveux décolorés il fume du crack
mais ça je vais vous féliciter quand
même parce que vous êtes un des rares
français qui prend des risques
rock'n'roll nous n'en parlons pas je
vous ai déjà dit à l'époque ce que j'en
pensais là c'est incroyable
et dans un monde comme ça où tout le
monde se regarde et où vous y avait
carrément vous avez pas peur guillaume
hoarau
[Applaudissements]
alors vous devez toujours être
évidemment excellent il ya une scène où
vous buvez du champagne on prend de la
coke avec vos copines qui vous suivent
partout vous mangez de la pâte d'anchois
logement au masters man et on va jamais
ça dans des films en france et hyperbare
et c'est génial c'est un grand
réalisateur ouais mais c'est vraiment un
bon et dans le fond et dans la forme
alors évidemment c'est une époque bénie
c'est l'époque où il y avait encore des
poils à un moment il ya une fille qui se
fait faire le ticket de métro et perdrix
fait ce que tout le monde est
dégueulasse
cc c'est une époque c'est une époque
charnière en fait entre ces post 68 et
avant l'arrivée du sida arrivée de la
vidéo et c'est une sorte de parenthèse
enchantée en fait on voit des
personnages qui sont super touchant
parce qu'ils sentent en fait que c'est
la fin d'une ère fin d'une époque qui
est une époque de liberté d'insouciance
de feu rappeler quand même que c'était
une époque aussi où les films pornos
cartonné ça faisait des millions
d'entrées savez pignon sur rue les gens
aller en coupe le voir des films pornos
déjà les aider quand il rentrait à la
maison ouais mais c'est non mais il
n'est pas du tout le même regard
là-dessus et puis il le faisait aussi
avec ce sentiment aussi de faire
peut-être un jour aussi un du cinéma
traditionnel et xavier beauvois qui peut
faire du lot exceptionnel fait
incroyable qu'il est l'humour de jouer
ce rôle dans un film que tournait en
pellicule ouais c'est à dire qu'à
l'epoque y avait de la pellicule a
aujourd'hui il ya la vidéo est sur la
vidéo on voit les verrues on voit les
points noirs on voit tous là l'époque
c'était un peu hamiltonien l'image quand
même hein et puis j'ai surtout une
époque des films où les gens s'amusent
est vraiment une joie de vivre qui était
propre aux années 70 aux années 80 parce
que ces tournages en fait sont des
moments de vacances sont des mondes de
plaisir des rapports sexuels y en a plus
en dehors du tournage que pendant le
tournage près tout à fait ça quand on a
rencontré des acteurs et des actrices
porno de l'époque et qui nous racontait
qu'effectivement c'était très convivial
très familiale et qu'il y avait c'était
c'était tout à fait normal nous a
raconté d'ailleurs que on souhaite elle
avait quitté son chéri non pas parce
qu'ils tournaient avec d'autres actrices
mais parce qu'il en avait invité une à
dîner
c'était chaud
non mais il y avait une insouciance et
une joie de vivre absolument incroyable
a dissipé un kamikaze a aussi la fille
dont elle est formée d'un amoureux elle
est un magnifique que les fraîches les
ailes ça gentiment quoi ya pas de vichy
a pas de weppes y sont ils sont comme je
disais ils sont tous vraiment humain et
c'est vrai que cédric il a cette qualité
de moi j'avais fait la prochaine fois je
viserai le coeur avec lui et il a pu le
même sur un personnage comme ça qui
était un serial-killer enfin un gendarme
tueur en série il arrive on arrivait à
le rendre touchant et là tous les
personnages sont attachants ils sont
tous quelque part un peu au départ paumé
et ensemble ils font ils font quelque
chose et je trouve ça assez
représentative de la nostalgie qu'on
peut avoir de cette époque là où on est
plus en plus dans une société
aujourd'hui qui se regarde le nombril et
qui est seul où on a des mecs qui font
des films chez eux sur leur ordinateur
et puis des spectateurs qui regardent
les films en cliquant sur un lien et on
est tous de plus en plus seul dans nos
trucs et la sarre montre à quel point
vivre ensemble c'est quand même assez
important bah oui le dernier cinéma
porno le beverly vient de vient de
fermer le petit marchand kleenex à côté
interrogé 2 j'ai fermé aussi évidemment
il ya un grand problème que vous risquez
d'avoir vivre c'est que les filles qui
jouent dans ces films ne sont pas
présentés comme des victimes
à une époque où on aime bien présente et
toujours les escortent les prostituées
comme des victimes quand il faut que ça
soit triste il faut qu'il ya un problème
extra et ces gens là ont l'air de
vraiment s'amuser de prendre du plaisir
est-ce que c'est politiquement correct
est ce que vous avez pas peur nous faire
emmerder par les féminines non parce que
c'est un témoignage d'une époque on
relate simplement une époque ccc on va
pas mentir sur va pas transformer la
réalité c'était comme ça et ça raconte
pas la période d'aujourd'hui c'est pas
mal de dérapage sur le tournage tu veux
nous en parler non mes cheveux non mais
je peux te dire par exemple que on était
persuadé avec gilles qu'on allait être
émoustillé par par le fait d'être avec
des fines eu sur le plateau et en fait
on était comme deux couillons maison
inscrit mes tables un peu surpris peur
or michel
vous savez que si vous continuez à
fréquenter cnic la dette obligé de
passer vos vacances au cap ferret elle a
regardé qu'ils avaient péri bah oui vous
savez ça qu'on aime mais j'aime pas les
vacances moi arrête ça tombe bien alors
vous êtes donc au cinéma avec guillaume
canet nous est avant tout un homme de
théâtre
on vous retrouve en ce moment au théâtre
de paris dans le fric frac d'edouard
bourdet que vous mettez en scène
également vous incarnez joe qui est un
délinquant un peu looser ami avec une
prostituée loup joué par julie depardieu
le rôle de arletty en 1936 et la
création de la pièce d'edward bordés et
vous décidez d'arnaqué laspalès qui est
un employé de bijouterie donc déjà ça
promet c'est pas vous qui jouez loulou
n'ont pourtant que vous adorez vous
travestir quand même ouais je suis trop
moche non il fallut deux loulous frais
qu'elle soit sexy douay non julie à une
évidence dans ce rôle formidable c'est
dur de passer par les ti en fait elle
elle fait avec le style de la pièce mais
sans son bon pied dans cette formidable
puisque fait en vous regardant femme
quand même à nistos serge merci non ce
que vous me donnez est immense
c'est la quête de toute une vie et à
travers moi c'est la grande famille du
théâtre que vous honorez et je voudrais
bien sûr remercie madeleine sologne
madeleine situe dans la salle pardon
pardon ce n'est pas mon mot lien ce
n'est pas mon molière non bien sûr c'est
le moyen de toute l'équipe non
à travailler ou de toucher
mais son argument
trop savoir ce qui se passait dans le
faux
quelques hommes matures
fumel
encore
c'est quelqu'un qui m'a dit
non
[Musique]
très heureux d'avoir mon plateau michel
fau est un génie on s'est
alors vite le travestissement fait
partie de l'histoire du théâtre c'est le
kabuki c'est le théâtre élisabéthain et
dès l'antiquité dans les pièces de
plaute les femmes étaient jouées par des
hommes donc c'est pas c'est pas nouveau
oui et puis après au 19e siècle c'était
les femmes qui jouent et les jeunes
hommes hamlet lorenzaccio ces jeux par
des fans vous reprocher à notre époque
son manque d'extravagance et vous dites
les jeunes comédiens jouent tous un peu
comme à la télé ou au bureau vous avez
raison non même les vieux aussi
oui un peu tout le monde joue un peu
pareil enfin ces sacs alors que je pense
qu'il ya pas un jeu qui est plus
légitime que l'autre il ya des notions
de style mais y'a pas ainsi que peu
léger devait aimer canet parce que lui
il y va à fond quand même un oui puis
les îles a de l'audace et un bouclier de
la fantaisie aussi beaucoup les
exactement et il est pas très
intelligent de le rappeler c'est presque
il fait pas ce qui fait
d'elle enfant alors vous passez sans
cesse d'un répertoire à l'autre vous
dites n'appartenir à aucune chapelle est
un combat ah oui je me sens un peu seul
mais je pense que c'est albert camus
disait qu'on est toujours seul donc je
pense que c'est le lot de l'artiste mais
en effet mais j'arrive encore à trouver
des producteurs et des comédiens qui
m'accompagne pour faire des spectacles
donc pour l'instant ça va vous avez une
réputation d' avenir un peu dans le
métier ah oui j'ai des gens qui ne
supportent pas oui mais mais comme
disait sacha guitry être aimé par tout
le monde sait être mais par n'importe
qui donc a envie d'être aimé par la
bonne tenue
alors il pourrait faire des grosses
têtes
je suis content c'est gagnant est plutôt
faire un peu tout faire vous dites je
suis dadaïste je suis contre le goût du
jour oui c'était ça les dadaïstes ouais
c'était magnifique second vendredi et
dès qu'ils ont été récupérés dès qu'ils
sont devenus un mouvement artistique
il n'était pas content prix un voyage de
la daïra possible en tant que cavalier
j'ai pas osé les affaires laurent baffie
défonça au sto à ça qu'on le reconnaît
et maintenant mesdames messieurs gérard
darmon remond choix
[Applaudissements]
du temps du temps que je n'ai pas vu
dans une de mes émissions vous doutez
bien à quel point je suis ému gérard
êtes ici ce soir pour l'ordre des choses
une pièce de marc faye et mise en scène
par richard berry que vous jouez avec
vincent desagnat et pascal louanges à
michodière le pitch faudra mieux vendre
la pièce c'est un peu le vertige en
avant mais un shopping voilà
[Musique]
alors vous avez 60 ans je vous ai dit 70
non mais attends dans la pièce est-ce
que c'est difficile de jouer un homme de
60 ans non pas du tout ça vous vous
faites très bien vous êtes marié avec
pascal louanges donc comme richard berry
en fait exactement exactement et un jour
vous et votre femme voyez débarquer
vincent desagnat nom qui à l'âge de
votre femme et il affirme tests adn à
l'appui
qui vit votre fils mais hélas il ya deux
problèmes ça c'est le pic je fais bien
le pitch un impeccable il y a deux
problèmes ça fait dix ans que j'ai
essayé de faire un enfant bravo de
charme et vous le faites pas non non
elle pense vous êtes stérile lie à votre
fils qui qui débarque premiers rôles
deuxième problème votre fils en pince
pour votre femme est là il ya cette
réplique culte donc parce que je suis
ton fils je n'ai pas le droit d'être
l'amant de la femme quand même pas mal
de quoi je réponds bah non comme à le
trouver non c'est très bien écrit
c'est très bien mis en scène par richard
bien il avait découvert en fait richard
berry j'ai découvert un train grand
mettant semaine il est très bon mais
pense qu'il est pédagogue absolument il
est bienveillant et les patients il a
beaucoup de qualités on exactement mais
celle ci c'est un bonheur j'imagine sa
mort tautavel ce genre de piège avait
pas l'habitude trop de les jouer très
légère comme ça qui en même temps
véhicule une espèce de discours plutôt
plus tôt il parce qu'à des thèmes comme
la pérennité la pma de ça mais c'est le
traité avec beaucoup de légères c'est
très moderne voilà et alors il ya une
bande-son d'en faire ça plairait
beaucoup à taurignan parce qu'il ya jimi
hendrix décide ici après les jets 6 10
alors là on vous voit jouer de la
guitare un peu comme un vieux rocker
quoi ce jeudi on est très peu joué les
guitares commun
hors garde à quoi ça ressemble magnéto
sinon lutherie que tu aimes la vie alors
j'aime bien le tennis
eric clapton
les jeans délavés et affame
le tennis dont je sais j'ai entendu ça
eric cape town
à la fin tout ça à ta femme à piedmont
où
tu ton groupe ils m'ont
laissé y auriez pas de me draguer par
hasard un peu vous avez quel âge thomas
pourquoi tout et tout est malade
maintenant voir si ça peut coller
ça colle tout à fait garanti oui mais là
nous on veut tout tu peux pas je vois là
pourquoi puisqu'on a les mêmes goûts oui
écoute on peut partager des choses des
sommes non alors excusez moi mais je
trouve ça particulièrement
discriminatoire parce que je suis pas
figé pas pas être un nom de ta femme
mais qui d'un coup
c'est à bellmer jeudi
[Applaudissements]
ma
bon
mais
alors c'est drôle parce que c'est la
bande annonce qu'on a fait juste avant
de répéter circo maintenant on n'est
plus du tout dans ce moule à ce que 10 à
thomas c'est comme si on faisait écouter
un piano voix comme ça par rapport à
leurs résultats ou une répète quoi mais
ça donne ça donne déjà la bande annonce
est une pièce sur la paternité vous qui
êtes un jeune papa j'imagine que ça vous
parle en fait je suis un jeune papa je
suis un vieux papa je veux parler de la
paternité parce que j'ai été papa à 20
ans puis entre 40 et 50
et après 69
année pédiatrique pédiatrique je lis bon
vous êtes un jeune papa et vous dites on
accueille mieux un bébé sur le tard
qu'on accueille à 20 ans c'est sûr mais
voilà donc j'ai dit une espèce de bonne
foi j'ai un truc super
alors évidemment vous avez qu'on a le
même âge je pense que vous êtes un peu
plus âgés que moi
sinon janvier 49 voilà c'est j'aurais
mieux fait de
carrière
alors but quand même un robot de notre
âge vous savez une m'arrive de gamberger
je pense à après mais je me dis qu'il ya
des gens autour de moi sa mère ses
frères et soeurs qui prendront le relais
quand on a 69 ans et qu'on a un bébé on
voit là on se dit combien de temps je
vais la voir grandir et elle va en même
temps donner l'énergie pour et puis et
puis par cette espèce d'insouciance qui
parfois nous caractérisons slim c'est
comme ça c'est le ciel qui a parlé ça
fait 20 ans que je vis avec ça le ciel
et la picarde la picarde la picarde
christine les toujours dans ma vie mais
c'est faux voilà de l'été onze idéal
avec la wii vous voulez bien bravo parce
que moi je le connais
alors venez donc une fille de 1 an une
fille de 50 ans une fille de 24 ans ray
un fils de 21 ans question paternité de
l'été galt est quand même un étude et
confond pas partout
mais votre fille est née à 50 ans de
plus que votre fille cadette quand même
oui c'était c'est aberrant non mon nom
mon petit fils a un an de moins que mon
fils avec
16,2 de part je ne sais pas mais il y
aura beaucoup de pioche voilà vous dire
une chose quand même j'ai rarement vous
êtes né un 29 février oui donc votre
anniversaire c'est tous les quatre ans
oui il est là j'avais 17 ans et demi en
fait exactement savait comment certains
ennemis vous êtes bissextile oui tu m'as
de l'epr non j'ai pas dis bisexuels où
il a passé loin j'ai compris absolument
je suis sextile bissextile mais quand
j'étais môme ça me ça me perturbait
parce que j'avais l'impression d'être de
d'être né un jour qu'il n'existe pas
quoi tout le monde avait son aîné radis
noir pour un mois sépare sauf c'est
quand même la grâce à tous les ans oui
mais le vrai gros anniversaire ses 29
ans et sa mère sont vides mais sa valeur
j'ai archi très heureux très heureux de
vous retrouver merci thierry à 1500
oui
et maintenant gerra on va faire un
shopping mais
[Musique]
voilà alors est-ce que vous avez besoin
de ça c'est fait ça s'appelle comment ça
s'appelle un baby je pense
oui en trente ans les enfants entrent en
jeu et tu fais quoi là dedans gérard
thépaut la saga natel
et ça ça s'appelle comme ça mais ça ça
s'appelle un lieu le 8 mars le baby ping
ont lieu le lit parapluie
[Applaudissements]
ça s'appelle comment ça
abc un baby cook pèse personne mais
cette voiture
chauffe avec un tas de trucs de
stérilisateurs
de lui dont il
pouvait pas coller les 25 ans bien ça je
connais moins parce que ma femme allaite
ah oui alain picard dallaire lapica
dalet
j'ai beau mondial robert ménard
petits doudous wipidoup la fin beau
et ça maintenant
[Applaudissements]
un mobile oui à musique ah oui
ça c'est le manège de villematier
remettait l'abattoir et sans
nom c'est une poubelle a alors oui
brasier
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tiens c'est l'heure deux vidéos
e
on va virer vous thiery très bien comme
il put alors qu'istres et qu'on a réduit
le budget
c'est sympa ça marche c'est comme les
gréements mais voilà c'est en moins en
moins en moins efficaces ont fait les
écoles et michaux temps pour trouver
tous cette saison vraiment sûr c'est la
deuxième saison ça va comme en france
inter alors mais très bien se sent plus
d'histoires de nicolas hulot à des
caennais qui vient il démissionne on
attend mâcon mais
[Rires]
attention ces dix ans
[Musique]
génial génial j'ai passé l'été à faire
de tous c'est très bien c'est vrai je
sais que vous avez passé un bel été
tranquille vous êtes resté bien à
l'ombre comme caris & booba
et moi j'ai passé des belles vacances je
suis parti très loin et j'ai disparu
comme redouane faïd est cette partie oui
qui marche bien je suis pas pour qu'on
les a gardés dix ans mais
l'info de la semaine c'est la rentrée
évidemment et les pas folichonne pour
tous emmanuel macron en déplacement à
laval en marge d'une rentrée
cauchemardesque qui a titré ce journal
et c'est vrai il y arrive que des tuiles
est la démission de hulot la démission
de flesselles les hésitations sur le
prélèvement à la source allez à laval
que le souci est là bas il a parlé que
les enfants il leur a dit professeur
c'est un beau métier et ça sert pour
être présidente jusqu'à preuve du
contraire on constate que propre ça sert
moins être président qu'à être première
dame mais c'est vrai qu'il ya un point
commun entre macro et hollande tous les
deux ont pris une maîtresse
allez politique française
marche de mieux en mieux à faire benalla
bfm tv diffuse la fiche de paye et le
contrat d'alexandre banana à l'elysée on
apprend qu'il gagnait
7113 euros par mois on n'avait pas vu un
arabe aussi bien payé pour mettre des
coups de boule depuis zinedine zidane
alors c'est vrai c'est bien p7100 13
euros par mois mais pour finir pour un
mec qui était à la fois gardes du corps
crs bagagistes agent secret et catcheur
semi-professionnels ses cadeaux dans la
série entourage du président le poste de
porte parole de l'elysée occupé par
bruno roger-petit va être supprimée
alors c'est cet ancien journaliste qui
avait tellement les schémas kron pendant
la campagne qu'il a été obligé de lui
inventer un poste de porte parole muet
en
tout cas si vous chez vous vous sentez
inutile dans la vie pensez à bruno
roger-petit après vous vous sentirez bon
combo
répondant à la polémique de la semaine
l'école jean michel blanquer re veut
redonner du prestige à la langue arabe
et oui bah c'est vrai que une langue
parlée par 350 millions de personnes
dans le monde et l'attendait jean michel
blanquer pour qu'on lui redonne un petit
peu de prestige l'idée de pouvoir
apprendre à l'école l'arabe comme on
apprend le russe ou le chinois aidant
c'est un choix alors l'extrême droite
ils se sont emballées réveillère des
cours d'arabe obligatoire à nos enfants
m'ont tous parlaient arabe et c'est
quand même marrant de se rendre compte
que les premiers à gueuler c'est ce qui
en 40 auraient été les premiers à
prendre de l'allemand
et d'un ministre à l'autre marlène
schiappa à présent le porno sur internet
ça évidemment ça touche tout le monde et
elle va exiger la mise en place de
filtres pour empêcher les enfants d'y
accéder la difficulté vivant c'est de
savoir quel filtre par mois j'ai testé
avec un filtre snapshot bon voilà c'est
oui c'est ça marche pas hyper bien ses
volets chapal se dit je vais envoyer des
images qui vont s'affiche la marlène
ses deux fils très très très bon mais
c'est pas mal des images vont s'afficher
dès qu'un mineur veut se connecter sur
un site porno pour le dissuader d'aller
plus loin et c'est pas mal comme idée
alors en exclusivité j'ai ces images
donc la première qui va s'afficher pouf
si tu cliques sur ce site géré venir
chez toi et si vraiment ils osent aller
plus loin là vraiment c'est impossible
avec une image suivante si tu dis
c'est oui j'ai alors qu'est-ce qui
s'aggrave et à mesure des semaines toi
tu vas toucher de la sacem
qui va tous déposés devant
politique internationale à kim jong-un
offre deux chiens au président
sud-coréen c'est assez sympa et aussitôt
cette annonce faite donald trump son
nouveau meilleur ami a réagi la ligue
kim j'espère qu'à moi tu va offrir deux
chiennes
c'est vrai que c'est assez sympa une
bonne ambiance internationale encore au
pérou les électeurs d'un petit village
ont le choix entre hitler et lénine
alors voilà c'est à l'air étrange comme
ça en fait ces deux candidats qui se
présentent aux élections dans le petit
village de young art qui se prénomme
respectivement l'un hitler et l'autre
lénine avec deux n des bons c'est rigolo
et le maire sortant s'appelle donc en
effet ickler alba nom mais le plus
dingue quand même c'est de voir la fiche
derrière il ya écrit hitler avec un
coeur sur le i on croirait les murs de
la chambre d'ado de marion maréchal
et son slogan véridique c'est je suis le
gentil hitler et ouais mais c'est pas
con mais qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
gentil clair précis c'est un gars qui te
met les juifs dans des trains pour les
emmener au parc astérix jeu c'est le
monde à l'envers on ne sait pas on
descend ou première classe
on reste en amérique du sud pédophiles
et l'archevêché chilien des conseils aux
prêtres d'embrasser les enfants sur la
bouche voilà comme ça c'est clair
l'archevêché chilien des conseils les
préliminaires
science en afrique du sud des chercheurs
ont réussi à donner naissance au premier
lion éprouvette c'est hyper mignon
échappe au chapeau parce que moi
franchement j'aurais pas aimé de celui
qui était chargé d'aller palucher le
pape a lyon
les judicieux
agression au couteau à paris on l'a
fusillé avec des boules de pétanque
c'était cette semaine sept personnes
blessées au couteau le long du canal de
l'ourcq l'homme d'origine afghane a été
interpellé grâce à un joueur de pétanque
tueur hausse et une moule en pleine tête
les français ne faut pas les faire chier
je peux vous dire mais surtout c'est
quand même le summum de l'humiliation
pour un musulman de servir de cochonnet
médias frédéric lopez kit rendez vous en
terre inconnue et à voir la tête de
certains quand ils ont appris l'info je
peux vous dire ce n'était pas facile
alors là les mursi d'ethiopie font une
gueule jusqu'à par terre et c'est
vraiment bête qu'il arrête on aurait
tous rêvé de voir didier deschamps dans
l'émission la tête qu'il aurait fait
quand il aurait appris que l'on emmené
chez le dentiste
champion du monde toujours le capitaine
des bleus hugo loris condamné pour
conduite en état d'ivresse à londres une
suspension de permis de 20 mois et 50
mille livres d'amandes en apprenant la
nouvelle franck ribéry aurait déclaré
cinquante mille livres déjà tu m'en
donnes un temps largement puni
international 2005 avait muselé par le
bas françois ce sont les deux premiers
ça a dû lui faire tout bizarre ou pape
françois de se retrouver pour la
première fois face à une paire de seins
ces logements sont mignons
malaise c'est long à monter mais cette
fois c'est bien c'est beau ouais c'est
ce qu'elle dit soutenir ou
un maire élu à pile ou face et ça je
peux vous dire heureusement que serge
dassault est décédé ça lui aurait fait
un choc de savoir qu'on peut influencer
une élection avec une seule pièce de
monnaie
revenons en france à tickets de métro
nouveaux débarquent à paris à partir de
ce lundi alors on va les voir comme ça
vous avez une idée à gauche c'est
l'ancien un ticket de métro et à droite
c'est le nouveau bon rien à voir ouais
ça va pas révolutionner le domaine de
l'épilation du maillot
si les masses il est ma chouette
informations les états unis prépare un
film sur redoine faïd alors évidemment
la grande question c'est mais qui va
jouer le rôle de redoine faïd un franco
algérien dont on perd complètement la
trace je pense que faudel a les bonnes
dispositions
klipfel
celui peut-être vous le saviez vous qui
étiez dans le showbiz mais moi pas
laeticia hallyday johnny l'avait chargé
de mettre fin à l'idylle entre laura
smet et doc gynéco dans un livre à
paraître sur laëtitia on apprend qu'elle
avait pour mission de ces paris laura
qui était alors âgée de 13 ans et doc
gynéco dont elle s'était entiché qui en
avait 22 donc apparemment à l'époque il
n'était pas que gynéco il était aussi
pédiatre
belgique c'est chez moi thierry rey
encore fier sur une base militaire un f
16 tirs accidentellement sur un autre
f-16 et le détruit comme je dis souvent
aux français ça explique un peu pourquoi
en 40 les allemands sont arrivés assez
vite chez vous voilà rien pu faire et la
dernière aux epesses génie ryan un jeune
homme de 22 ans arrêté pour avoir eu des
relations sexuelles avec le pot
d'échappement de sa voiture alors bon
apparemment la voiture était consentante
puisqu'elle n'avait pas allumer les feux
de détresse mais
véridique mais ça existe s'appelle la
mécano phyllis important de le savoir
alors évidemment ya des variantes si
vous êtes excité par une mini c'est de
la pédo un mécano hafidi si vous êtes
excès par une deux chaussées de l'ase au
mécano philly s'est excitée par une lada
c'est de la nécro mécano fille dit quoi
l'artiste de la semaine va rester c'est
joli ça ouais ouais j'ai envie donc
vraiment m'intéresser un immense artiste
du 20e siècle je veux parler de miro
mire non non je vous dis non mais non
mais non mais miro le peintre oui oui
c'est con mais ça marche
juan miro évidemment dont 150 oeuvres
sont exposées actuellement au grand
palais né à barcelone puis a émigré à
paris avant de retourner mourir en
espagne exactement le même trajet que
manuel valls est passé par les
influences fauviste cubiste
expressionniste et il finit par trouver
son style onirisme et sur réalise on va
voir quelques heures sans nous
connaissez vous appréciez il ya des
offres on reconnaît tout de suite voilà
savons c'est cdu miro c'est un peu le
bordel on se croirait dans la tête de
nadine morano quand on lui pose une
question d'économie
mais pour en arriver là évidemment il ya
eu tout un style qui s'est créé d'autres
oeuvres on va voir celle-ci voilà qui
est assez mignonne c'est une peinture
bas qui sans doute est un petit clin
d'oeil à dominique strauss kahn
puisqu'il s'agit d'une femme de chambre
qui montre sa chatte et je vous avais
prévenu qu'elle
[Applaudissements]
est ici voilà une oeuvre qui aurait pu
être sous titré bon est ce qui marche ou
pas ce stylo
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
évidemment a parfois avec miro le titre
du tableau n'aide pas regardez comme
c'est joli et bien le titre exact ces
paysans catalan avec une guitare et on
ne reconnaît ni le paysan catalan ni la
guitare et on voit bien les qu il voit
et voilà ici une de ses oeuvres les plus
célèbres c'est un triptyque magnifique
immense qui s'appelle l'espoir du
condamné à mort et on reconnaît vraiment
pas le condamner à mort et on a surtout
l'espoir d'un jour y comprendre quelque
chose et ce qui m'a rassuré et je suis
allé moi à l'exposition est donc j'ai vu
par exemple un tableau et je me suis dit
mais qu'est ce qu'il a bien voulu
représenter et je me suis approché et
j'ai lu la légende de leur pays la paix
lui-même painting peinture parce que
lui-même il savait pas très bien de quel
avait peint et donc ça m'a complètement
rassuré alors dans le schéma qui sont
plus claires ou alors celle ci voilà qui
est je pense un très très beau tableau
et c'est vrai que l'on reconnaît bien
que c'est eric zemmour en train de
gueuler sur hapsatou sy parce qu'elle
s'appelle poitrine
[Musique]
et je terminerai par la dernière c'est
peut-être mon oeuvre préférée parce que
parce qu'elle représente voilà c'est
l'hommage de miro à picasso le tableau
s'appelle hommage à picasso et c'est
donc un mec qu'il faisait des
personnages tout déformé qui rend
hommage à un mec qui déjà un faisait des
personnages tout déformé c'est un petit
peu comme s'ils philippe croizon rendait
hommage à michel petrucciani et et moi
ça m'a ému allez-y elle est vraiment
grandiose cette expérience parce que la
politique
commente avec elie semoun le chante east
d'abord senti ce rush hantise votre
nouvel album s'appelle des paroles en
l'air il sera dans tous les bacs le 28
septembre alors que beaucoup moins beau
ça y'a un côté bosser plus fiable quand
même un vrai c'est un peu plus jazz a
cédé en fait c'est décédé moi je trouve
ces des jolies mélodies sur les ballades
j'aime bien la mélancolie mais pas la
mélancolie où on se met une balle dans
la tête et on achète une corde etc mais
la jolie la gentille mélancolie on va
dire ou des balades ya quelque chose à
dire jonathan non non non je suis en
train de parler mais
ferme et ailleurs avec
sept ans en s'entraînant comme ça
alors vite dit je retrouve le plaisir de
faire de belles chansons de retourner en
studio d'exprimer des choses que je
n'exprime pas quand je suis sur scène
prêts mais il n'a pas écouté l'album
qu'est ce que je vais te dire mais bon
je vais la saisir a déclaré la guerre
j'ai dit la vidéo ça c'est les amis non
mais vous dites je sais que les copains
vont se moquer mais je m'en fous
si jamel debbouze se mettait à chanter
des chansons d'amour je me faudrait
aussi de sa gueule oui non non c'est non
mais je le sais j'en suis à mon
troisième album et avait dit je vais
jamais au deuxième
en fait ça s'est passé d'une façon bête
j'étais dans ma voiture j'entends un
rapport à la radio je trouve qu'il écrit
bien je trouve qu'il chante bien c'était
un peu mélancolique un peu sombre et sa
ouvert quelque chose chez moi je me suis
dit tiens je verrai écrire des chansons
et j'ai appelé marc di dominico wii qui
avait fait l'album d'henri salvador
chambre avec vues je lui ai dit tu te
rappelles il ya des années elle m'avait
proposé de faire un disque faisons le
mais voilà on est en train de nous
expliquer que tout allait bien roulé ce
jour là n'ont pas eu cette merde
septembre
[Applaudissements]
saleh
quand on est entré les gens demandent
plus souvent quand est ce que pour
former votre duo avec dieudonné que
quand est-ce que vous sortez moi je
monte je suis pas je suis pas le mec le
plus attendu dans le monde de la musique
oui mais c'est pas grave gg c'est non
mais j'ai essayé de faire ça avec une
grande sincérité j'aime le jazz j'aime
l'écriture j'aime la poésie j'aime les
balades donc voilà c'est mon deuxième
saut et on a fait merci tisser bref nos
déchets
[Applaudissements]
c'est que c'est le troisième album de
lui on n'est pas à l'abri d'un best-of
alors les paroles sont de vous oui les
musiques sont des manuels données d'adp
le pire souchon et du regretté hugonnier
mais tous alors je rappelle pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas il faisait partie
de la sphère louis' trio ana et c'était
un mélodiste génial et il m'avait fait
une mélodie d' pour le deuxième album je
n'avais pas prise et puis je me suis dit
je vais lui rendre hommage soit là bas
lui permirent la production vous l'avez
dit c'est marc di domenico banks
effectivement et pas n'importe qui mal
et au dj je glisse le long de la page
blanche
et me rattrape of le coup il ya tant à
dire que je flanche
au creux de ma main
ça fout
je me passe toutes les séquences
de mon cinéma de minuit
s'était débarrassé le titre de l'album
est une chanson qui s'appelle
mademoiselle jojo et vous dites dans
cette chanson je me dois de vous
expliquer pourquoi je n'ai pas su vous
aimez donc on promet que ça fait
référence à joséphine ah oui clairement
en récession mais non il sait pas le
faire
les bailleurs dont le livre dont on va
parler après il ya encore joséphine oui
bah oui bah oui oui je me suis servi
forcément de ce que j'ai vécu
contrairement à la demoiselle qui nous
fait croire que c'est le contre
alors qu'on met dans la semaine des
prénoms c'est incroyable c'est une
malédiction une bénédiction il ya une
chanson s'appelle le prénom oui le
prénom vous dit dans cette chanson et ça
résoudrait tous les problèmes avec
zemmour vous dit ton prénom ça m'est
égal bah oui parce que vous dites mon
amour
c'est un homme simple c'est bien
pourquoi c'est à dire aux gens mon amour
plutôt que un corps et
lui dit mon amour il n'y a pas de prénom
de volée
à côté de l'autre parent tout est écrit
un
lecteur un petit bout du prénom
c'est comme ça que je t'aime
ton prénom sam est hagard
pas besoin de plus ma mère
c'est bien
et y en a eu la main très cher
s'appelle ravel et debussy
harris rg sur la masturbation féminine
exactement alors même érotique ouais
elle dirige la musique sur sa peau
élastique élastique elle a stick
évidemment et ouais elle était
sur le canapé
les yeux clos ou presque
debussy
[Musique]
oui c'est mon album s'appelle dans la
finance mondiale c'est dans les bacs le
28 septembre et maintenant on continue
le shopping
on passe aux livres jeux compagnie portr
servi de grenier
voit la jolie qui certaines pelouse
interdite non non non c'est patrick sur
l'homosexualité
féminine pelouse interdit pas dit alors
toulouse interdite c'est le journal d'un
amoureux des plantes évidemment c'est
vous oui c'est aux éditions ulmer ça
sort le 4 octobre alors le pitch en fait
c'est l'histoire de votre jardin du val
d'oise et quelques anecdotes
personnelles qui se cache derrière votre
activité de jardinier on va dire que
c'est pas c'est pas un le mode d'emploi
pour com comment planter faille non
gelée coécrit avec didier ville et ricky
lui un grand spécialiste des plantes et
c'est plutôt ma vision d'artiste sur le
jardin ou sur les plantes en fait je
peux donner des conseils mais c'est pas
non c'est pas mon truc non vont le voir
comme un
non mais je l'écris comme un amoureux
des plantes d'humour la nature exacte
j'ai fêté en potager j'ai pas de trucs
comme ça voici les fleurs j'aime
du côté du brésil
ces gens font la honte qui est un vrai
ami oui si vous voulez connaître le vrai
elie visiter son jardin ouais je me dis
parfois qu'ils préfèrent les plantes aux
hommes non c'est un peu exagéré mais
mais quand tu as failli et l'applaudir
je sais pas pourquoi toi
non mais on applaudit on partage on
partage lui et moi l'amour des plantes
oui mais sur la porte de ces toilettes
et marquer silence ça pousse donc
google
fait en parallèle entre votre potager
votre ex donc si vous aviez un projet
commun de tous et vous dites que le
potager n'a rien donné joséphine est
parti j'étais trop impatient bien qu
avec les femmes il faut être convaincu
les plans ne faut pas être trop pressé
mais faut pas être trop pressé c'est
vrai je suis impatient j'ai envie de
parce que je réfléchisse vite j'agis
vite donc on court à ce culte des faits
sauf que le melon sacré vite réfléchi
mis dix minutes à défendre une heure que
je me coq je me
une heure que je me contrôle pourquoi te
foute une tarte dans la gueule tu n'a
rien à faire dans cette émission
retourne chez arthur s'ils violent là
c'est comme ça
pas encore si on leur dit que j'aime
mettre les mains dans la terre je trouve
cet échange physique avec le jardin
quasi sensuelle je caresse les feuilles
comme si je caressais le chevelure oui
enfin c'est pour un grand malade non
j'ai un texto de tares de tes voisins
inquiets de te voir nue
non je suis pas le genre à parler aux
plantes mais en tout cas je suis le
genre aller baiser comme c'est vrai que
c'est vrai que je le dis parfois même
quand il m'arrive n'allons compte
heureusement de casser à une branche
je m'excuse elles furent alors non le
grand ennemi des lits c'est le frelon
asiatique
le frelon asiatique
tu m'en serais ce sujet parce que là je
suis à cran les frelons asiatiques ils
sont vraiment ils sont tous dans le
xiiie pour l'instant
combien
et vous avez tellement les abeilles que
vous êtes fait tatouer une abeille sur
l'épaule oui c'est vrai est-ce que vous
avez d'autres copies qui sont tatouées
sur votre corps il a une ruche sur
l'autre épaules alors il essaie de faire
rentrer la belle coïncidence
il ya un truc que je comprends pas si
vous avez un paquet comprend mon avis si
vous avez un passe temps de retraité
qu'allez vous faire quand bouscat des
retraites bah je suis obligé de répondre
à cette question et du nom d'accord
merci
c'est bon ça va très bien j'étais dans
ma loge je viens un peu en avance et je
pensais à nos et et nous en chiffres tu
sais ce que ça donne nous en chine ça
fait 28 ans de collaboration thierry
632 émission 2700 heures
d'enregistrement
plus de 5000 coupe de champagne 11 kilos
de deux boeufs on skie dont
400 filles baiser banque publique
trente deux plaintes pour viol quatre
mariages et un enterrement 300 invités
partis fâchés 28 procès et 13 coloscopie
on est bien tombé des nues et bien c'est
bon quand tu arrives là que je suis
arrivé sur le tu veux pas trop se mettre
tout nu
ce soir c'est un couple ils viennent de
faire l'amour et la fille lui dit alors
ça t'a plu est fait non c'est nul
franchement tu baises comme un lapin et
dit maintenant tu peux pas le juger en
10 secondes
[Applaudissements]
en hommage à michel blanc et noémie
lenoir on va faire un hardi quiz quand
ils sont morts rouleur le winner aura
droit à un éloge de la part de thierry
ardisson le looser aura droit à un éloge
mais par laurent baffie ah oui
alors testé au buzzer d'abord on
m
[Musique]
à
toi rémy il faut que tu appuies
santana
quand vous pensez avoir la réponse
évidemment vous appuyer sur notre buzzer
et vous répondez se mettre avec ma fille
oui oui des capotes alors moi des
capotes du premier âge petite taille
petit des
appareils est un village
le crès
comment s'appelle le peintre qui ne
peint en noir
apaise
réconforte console ou soulager
soulage les appuyer en 28 marche parce
que là ça commence
[Musique]
classez vous vous demandez pourquoi
néron adorent et il la couleur verte
parce que sa mère portait une bague en
émeraude parce qu'il aimait courir nus
dans l'herbe parce qu'il était né un
soir de lune verte ou parce qu'il
adorait manger des poireaux
parce qu'il était né un sens de l'insee
nord
[Applaudissements]
parce que sa mère portait une bague
émeraude morts
il adorait courir nus dans l'herbe
bernard vient de dire non on a tous fait
relative asie michel il en reste une
c'est une victoire et le
patrimoine n'est pas celle de liste en
île était dingue duverne héros étaient
dingues du vert dans les jeux du cirque
qui se met toujours les écuries verte de
ses demandes et des bleus il avait une
collection de l'émeraude et néron
adorait pas parce que mes choux adoré
les poireaux il est en bleu belgique
dans cet effort
pourquoi les blues des chirurgiens sont
elles verte parce qu'on brasse paraît a
lancé la mode en 15 150 parce que c'est
la couleur qui fait le mieux ressortir
le sont parce que le vert est la couleur
de l'espoir ou parce que blanc c'était
trop salissant
je frappe comme un dingue la musique ne
sort pas
parce que ambroise paré a lancé la mort
parce que c'est la couleur qui fait le
plus ressentir bravo messieurs
alors là c'est facile attention
de quelle couleur sont les boîtes noires
des avions
[Applaudissements]
je persiste à dire ça marche quand
quelqu'un me et non il fait le premier
accusé était pour lui non je suis très
mauvais soir dans les yeux parmi les
tableaux suivants lequel n'a pas été
réalisé par un enfant de moins de 5 ans
[Musique]
en haut à gauche je pense bravo
un tableau des lacs bravo messieurs
gland est en fait les autres ont été
faits par des gens de l'âge de 2-3
carrie cinq ans effectivement donc on en
est où là
blanc prend la tête
mal benfica
on voit
quelle maladie n'existe pas la fièvre
bleue la cne rose la mycose violacé ou
le syndrome du struma argenté
lettre la mycose viola sais pas comment
tu sais ça fait trois fois
le syndrome du shoot out c'est assez
hallucinant ça existe un c'est une
maladie qui s'appelle largué risme et
qui est provoqué par l'absorption
d'argent colloïdal ça m'arrive souvent
j'ai jamais ressenti de sa
c3 attention
là c'est vraiment une question de
rapidité
il est exclu
citez moi un personnage de fiction avec
un nom de couleurs
[Musique]
à
super rebela prince albert wibp la
panthère est ce que ce papa
avec sa
planche mais
on est à égalité donc le super banco
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes prêts quelle est la couleur la
plus populaire dans le monde
le bleu le rouge le vert le noir
c'est moi
[Musique]
oui c'est le bleu le blanc mais comment
vous savez ça l'est parce que je le sais
bah oui la réponse est bon chez michel
blanc de pardon non
les spectateurs
pourquoi
michel blanc adroits les loges et l'anti
loges sera pour williams
michel
quoi de plus naturel
que de faire l'éloge de l'acteur le plus
culte du cinéma français culte parce que
vous êtes la coqueluche des français les
zips à sable parce que vous êtes
hypocondriaque michel il n'y a pas un
français qui ne pensent pas à vous
lorsqu'il prend le télésiège
ses vacances ski
une lorsqu'il est fleur du pied une
touffe d'orgue sera la plage en été pas
un français qui n'est une pensée émue
pour vous
lorsqu'il se prend un râteau
alors qu'il pensait lui aussi que sur un
malentendu ça pouvait marcher
cultes michèle parce que vous avez su
sublimer le rôle du loser magnifique au
physique pas facile pour en faire un
héros que des générations et des
générations de français n'oublieront
jamais michel michel vous savez que les
français vous aime tellement qu'il
pourrait tout vous pardonner même les
bronzés 3 et ça c'est une preuve d'amour
[Applaudissements]
m
bon j moment des lentilles l'ensilage de
vue d'amener dit rihanna c'est une
carrière naissante i qui démarre grâce à
une présence inouïe un sens de la
promotion à toute épreuve une répartie
désarçonnante 1 et il trouve à lui seul
qu'on peut allier
acting et drogues douces
[Musique]
oui elle ne fera rien de sa vie il le
sait mais tant qu'on ne parle pas de son
micro pénis il est heureux
allez voir william
[Applaudissements]
louis bertignac un bon soir
[Musique]
plus personne me casse les couilles avec
la réformation de téléphone puisque
entre 2015 et 2017 téléphone s'est
refermée c'est en voyant peter et sloane
que vous avez
décidé de vous former avec jean-louis
j'imagine alors effectivement reformer
sous le nom les insu je comprends qu'il
n'y a pas le droit d'utiliser le mot de
téléphone pour des raisons juridiques
mais pourquoi pas un smartphone c'est
plus marrant je les inciterai plus
intelligents vont alors il ya un
téléspectateur qui aimerait savoir quand
se reforme les insu
ça n'arrête pas c'est toute ma vie ces
cons alors jamais je crois non c'est
vrai - arrête autant jamais rejoué avec
jean louis aubert mais si on va rejouer
horreur
on attendait on vous aime nous mais moi
aussi je vous aime d'accord je ne sais
pas
[Musique]
alors là oui vous êtes ici pour un album
intitulé origine d'abord on regarde la
pochette on voit qu'il y avait une
petite jeune parce que même lui ne ronge
plus sa chambre mais c'est exactement ça
c'est la chambre de votre famille coin
non non c'est une fausse chambre qu'on a
fait pour l'occasion un alors le pitch
de l'album reprendre en français
quatorze morceaux qui vous ont influencé
et qui vous ont construit en fait en
tant que musicien vous avez écrit les
adaptations françaises des shows l
anglaise ou américaine vous jouer de
tous les instruments sur cet album est
ce que vous l'avez enregistré chez vous
bien sûr de votre home studio en lisière
de la forêt de fontainebleau exactement
dans la maison qui a appartenu à didier
lockwood exact est un musicien
exceptionnel et qui est décédé il ya une
année par non yanan de didier le coût de
la barre forcément vrai et vous avez
vous avez tous fait là-bas tout seul
quoi avec votre petite femme même pas
les tenants et les mois d'été
j'ai arrêté de bosser pour aller à
chercher aux
accents voter on regarde aquasar son
magnéto serge
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
du savon
je tue
c'est vous
[Applaudissements]
chanson de soir 3 6 voire assez récente
ouais bien sûr alors c'est un album fort
mis là pour tous ceux qui aiment le rock
qui sont nuls en anglais parce que vous
avez fait des adaptations mais toutes
ces chansons une réinterprétation on en
compte ma vie
ses chansons d où
isabelle one get fooled again c'est pas
la musique des experts seulement non oui
du monde connaît bavarois il aime la
chanson deus un génial my generation
merveilleux dit que je trouve un mec
qu'à mon âge
y en a une il y en a une que moi
j'aurais choisi c'est celle là
[Musique]
soit
ça fait plaisir bravo
merci
parce que c'est tombé sur les bicoques
c'est toi tu es sont pompés dans guitar
il faut qu'on ait aujourd'hui c'est vrai
que harrison j'étais obligé ouais c'est
génial il ya ça aussi
déchirée qui
[Musique]
qui
tu fumes
kemmer
je vais vous dire c'est un plaisir
c'est que quand même changé d'un bien
coaché cape town évidemment alors vous
avez plus s'acoquine plutôt que cocaïne
la cause des enfants mais n'ont pas
spécialement mais c'est la cocaïne c'est
pas mon truc ouais c'était plutôt
l'hérault vous exactement l'hérault et
le shit l'hérault et le chic alors mais
j'ai arrêté mais je suis trop vieux il
nous est arrivé la même chose mon cher
ami à la main exactement dan choi pas
que les drogués
encore des problèmes pas toi quand tu te
piquent pas même site us leaf tu peux
attraper il atteint dit que c'est
d'ailleurs j'ai eu deux mois aussi ah
ouais on n'attrape pas des maladies
seulement se shootant on peut attraper
des maladies en sniffant parce que la
paille elle passe à tout le monde c'est
vrai je te le dire ici la paille mais
conservatoire
c'est bon à dire pardon d'être un peu
cru mais ils sont mais pas de sous pulls
des fois on peut choper un ruffier
allons-y
comme ça dès l'origine ouais alors vous
n'avez jamais eu envie inouïe de
retrouver vos racines je pas vous êtes
né à oran l'algérie tout ça passe pas
vraiment non je ne sais pas c'est pas
mes vraies origines mais vraies origines
c'est les beatles les stones c'est ma
vraie vie c'est ça ouais j'ai été joué
j'ai joué alger une fois avec téléphone
là je me suis dit ah ouais c'était un
petit j'étais jeune je serai pas là je
fais pas aller en france à 3 ans je
répète là comme ces petits gamins en
train de jouer au foot ou
menon non content mais on s'est fait
virer oui je sais c'est donc ça c'est
pas du tout envie des retours depuis
c'est clair alors votre père s'occupait
en fait à rendre la maintenance dix huit
boxes et jean box et des flippers des
trucs voilà donc il vous a donné le truc
parce que quand il entendait richard's
il s'est tu vois ça ce mec là tu vois
c'est un génie ce mec ouais ouais et
c'est ça qui la fuit les deux virus en
fait peut-être un peu où elle fait on a
toujours envie de plaire à son papa
ouais et mais à l'époque je me suis mis
vraiment à la musique ça lui plaisait
pas du tout parce qu'il espérait que je
serai médecin allawi est de faire de la
musique et en plus il assure ben haim dr
benhabib pour vous on ferait un petit
prix il n'y a pas il n'a pas du tout
apprécié en plus une fois il m'a chopé
en train de fumer avec des potes 1 mais
il a presque plus rien il dit à mon fils
et qui était leur brillante élève il est
foutu ça va être un clochard n'a pas
aimé et l'avenir lui a donné raison
mais dix ans après il est rien quand
vous avez eu du succès j'imagine que
voilà il a quand même ouais ouais bien
sûr ouais m'a dit j'ai été chez le
boucher aujourd'hui j'ai commandé un
truc il m'avait quand j'ai dit mon nom
il m'a dit vous connaissez louis
bertignac c'est mon fils
alors on termine avec vous l'avez sur le
bout de la langue le blind test
[Musique]
alors le thème du blind test aujourd'hui
c'est le bistouri c'est à dire des
chanteurs et des chanteuses qui ont eu à
faire la chirurgie esthétique c'est en
hommage évidemment un rock'n'roll
évidemment vous aviez vous a dit j'ai
fait du botox donc j'avais jamais voilà
du bon temps ça devait être très mal
fait parce que je pense qu'il y en a qui
on sent que c'est plutôt bien réussi
mais moi j'étais un peu momifié alors ça
m'a fait rachète un blanchiment de
l'anus mais je n'en parle pas par pudeur
rapide sur téléfoot vous jouez tous
contrebas fille attention brancher la
guitare
on tenait le temps mort ouais jacques
odm abbas 1 2 3 4 et non
[Musique]
la
dir weh
n'a rien fait c'étaient les gens de
regarder la ouais ouais c'est vrai je
compte c'est d'avoir mis car rien fait
bon on continue on se concentre
afin que tous vos besoins
[Musique]
fresnoy proche d'en avant guingamp
mois pour zazie un point pour laurent
baffie vous comptez en régie attention
emma
aoued accepte
j'attends
hans
trichet
j'ai fait une connerie de la m ben oui
rien n'a rien fait on peut
hematabad ta faute tu as nancy n'ont
rien fait ils ont rien fait les grands
bold and avec cyril hanouna mais eux je
crois que c'est un problème ils ont une
maladie deux ans
je pense qu'ils ont nommée maintient sur
tous les fronts
mais ils ont fait la géorgie pour
essayer de réparer sa part voit bien la
charge
uma
[Musique]
c'est
je tends
m
ailleurs
j'ai magnifique ce
chapitre à sonny and cher bon attention
emma
[Musique]
oui j'ai pas où sont les femmes pas de
jouer
shana
celle en vrac et moi c'est dangereux de
s'endormir près d'un an
[Musique]
à
on fait des gitans le
vilain soin papier du barreau
grands singes à
l'essai
il est généreux mais une mauvaise photo
et voilà on se retrouve quand même que
le verdit son attention et ma démarche
est là
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
l'importance de mettre une bonne crème
solaire
attention séquence ans à mon avis cela
parlé à michel fau et m'a
[Musique]
tuer
et maintenant on se fait un petit super
banco un petit 6 par an contre celui ou
celle qui va répondre à la question
suivante aura gagné le blind test et
sera obligé de m'y mets une célébration
de foot je sais quand les joueurs de
foot marque un but ils font des trucs
des dans ses pages des pères ne
chantera pas envie de devenir attention
je suis par bongo est mort
[Musique]
ils n'ont rien fait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention se concentre et mal
j'ai dit ah oui cacher son visage ne
savait plus comment faire
et oui ah oui ophélie winter
j'ai
les jeux pour la guimauve alors comment
ça se passe au foot quand on gagne pas
idiot
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu